يبدو ان الجدل حول فيلم الحاره لم ينتهي
في الاردن بعد فمن وسائل التواصل الى
الشارع وصل الهجوم الى سده البرلمان في
عمان النائب الاردني سليمان ابو يحيى هاجم
الفيلم زاعما انه ينتمي لمجموعه من
الافلام التي تسيء لسوره الاردن النائب
الاردني طالب بصحب جنسيه بطل الفيلم
الفنان منذر رياحنه مؤكدا انه اساء
للاردنيين والاردن الانا ريحنا لم يسكت عن
الامر ودافع عن الفيلم مؤكدا انه يحاكي
شريحه وفي مظلومه من الشعب الاردني
[موسيقى]
ايش رايك في يعني الجدل الجدل الفيلم وصل
الى قبه البرلمان دعوه لسحب جنسيتك من من
نائب بتهمه الاساءه للاردن كيف ترد على
هذه الدعوه
يا صديقتي
اظن في عنا اشياء همم
ومهام للنواب كبيره جدا اطول من من هذا
اللي بصير ولكن بالنسبه لاخر الاشياء اللي
صارت همم راح ننتظر القانون والقضاء
الاردني لانه اظن صار في همم في لقطه كبير
يعني وصار في اساءه بشكل شخص طيب
هل اليوم كل واحد مش عاجبه شو بيعمل الاخر
نطالب بسحب الجنسيه يعني لا مطلب قانوني
ولا مطلب دستوري اريد ان اسمع تعليقك اولا
ستي البرلمان الاردني هذا سقف الكلام في
مرفوع وزي ما بده الواحد بيحكي بعبر عن
الراي اللي بيحتاجه نقدر عن الفكره اللي
بده يحكي فيها ما في اي مشكله بموضوع شو
طرح الزميل وشو طلبات الزميل وايجابي على
موضوع انه خلصت المشاكل كلها بس احنا ما
ضل عندنا غير هذه المشكله
اختي العزيزه في احنا عندنا في مجلس
النواب لجنه اسمها لجنه التوجيه الوطني
والاعلام والثقافي هذه اللجنه تعني
وتتابع جميع ما يتعلق بموضوع الاعلام
وموضوع الثقافه وموضوع
النشر داخل المملكه وانا احد اعضاءها فهذا
شيء طبيعي انه يكون يهتم فيه طبيعي انه
متابعه منه طبيعي يشوف احنا ما يتم توجيهه
لمواطننا ولا جميعا اللي موجودين بالبلد
فهاي من صميم شغلنا ومن عملنا احد اللي
جاني موجوده كما يوجد لجنه ماليه كما يوجد
لجنه همم سياحيه كما يوجد لجنه نقل لجنه
طب منذر بعض يقول انه نقل معاناه الشعب
الاردني ليس بالضروره ان يكون بوضع
الشتائم والفاظنا بيه في الفيلم كيف ترد
يعني اساءه بحسبه همم احنا حكينا وشرحنا
لاكثر من مره بانه احنا اخذنا شريحه من
المجتمع وقدمناها كما هي اه الان بحكي لك
بانه الفن همم مراه المجتمع او شيء واقع
او كذا هذا الشيء موجود
والكل يعترف فيه يعني انا اخر تعليق سمعته
كثير حلو من بنت بتحكي طب بندر لما عملنا
فيلم رعب وجبنا فيه اشباح راح يطلعوا
يحكوا فش اشباح عنا يعني انا مش فاهم اللي
صار زائد انا ما بحبش حد يزاود علي يعني
همم اظن في حكايه موجوده همم
يعني السيد سالم بيعرف فيها بشكل شخص
بالنسبه للعنف والالفاظ اللي همم موجوده
في جزء من المجتمع همم يعني من حقنا اننا
نعمل سبوت لايت عليها همم
هذه البيئه التي ظلمت
فانتجتها هكذا خاص زائد انا بحكي للمره
المليون هذا المتر هذا الفيلم لا يمثل
عاداتنا ولا تقاليدنا ولا كل هذه التفاصيل
هذا بيمثل شريحه من المجتمع من المجتمع اه
همم صار عليها كل هذا الظلم نتيجه هذا
الظلم تم وجود هذول الاشخاص
اردني مؤخرا وتخرج الاصوات لا يمثلنا ولا
يمثلنا يعني اريد ان اسمع اين هي هذه
المدينه الفاضله التي لا يوجد فيها اشخاص
يتلفضون بعبارات سيئه يرتكبون افعالا
مسيئه او ربما حتى جرائم تمام سيدتي انا
بقول انا معك ومعي الاستاذ منذر بهذا
الموضوع احنا بنحكي هاي الطبقه موجوده
صحيح انا لا انكر وهذه الالفاظ موجوده
بالمجتمع لكن انا عندي ان كان لا شغله
واحده انكار اربط هذا الاسم بالحاره لا
باعطيه اسم ثاني للفيلم بعطيه العصابه
بعطيه قصه حياتي بعطي الاشرار طب كيف يعني
انا ربطت اسم الحاره الاردنيه بهذه
الجزئيه منها الناس عرفت وين المؤاخذه
المؤاخذه الفكره انه ليش اربطها باسم
الحاره على عيني ورجعتها
وبنتعامل فيها مش سميته الفيلم الحاره ههه
ههه